It's a miracle that Jaya Sable is still alive.
She was disfigured by an acid attack, and
she has suffered from its effects for years.
Her brother Satish has taken his 27-year-old
sister to get her twelfth operation.
Jaya's attacker was her husband and his parents.
The reason: she had given birth to a baby
girl instead of a boy.
"Nobody from my husband’s family came to
visit me in the hospital -- because I gave
birth to a girl."
Dr. Ganesh Rakh specializes in cases like
Jaya's.
He helps her feel human again.
For years, he's been campaigning against women
aborting their female fetuses or killing their
baby girls.
He's become something of a hero for taking
no payment whenever a girl is delivered in
his clinic.
"The thinking here is that the family isn’t
complete without a boy.
Males are seen as the ones who carry on the
family’s lineage.
Girls are seen as a burden.
The girl’s family has to pay a large dowry
to see her married.
They also have to pay all the wedding expenses."
Using ultrasound to determine the sex of a
fetus is strictly prohibited in India.
But it's still widespread, Dr. Rakh says.
It's just a question of money.
Angel, who's just six days old, is in many
ways lucky to be alive.
Her parents didn't know her gender until she
was born.
Her grandmother had hoped for a boy.
As a mother of six girls, she suffered under
social pressure until the birth of her seventh
child, a boy.
"I felt like I was finally successful.
At last, everyone one shut their mouths.
People had made it a point to come and visit
me when I had daughters so they could taunt
me.
They stopped after I had my son."
Dr. Rakh continues his outreach wherever he
can.
Away from his clinic, he offers encouragement
to pregnant women who are wary of giving birth
to baby girls.
"Sometimes we need to pay more attention to
a case.
If I feel that a patient has reacted negatively
when I tell her she might have a girl, then
she should have more counseling and follow
up.
Our aim is to ensure that the fetus remains
healthy and grows well, and won't be aborted.
On this evening, Angel and her mother are
sent home from the clinic with flowers and
cake.
Usually this kind of celebration with cake
and flowers is reserved for women who've just
delivered baby boys.
But on this evening, there's a different rallying
call.
These people are chanting, "Save the girlchild,
save the country.”